alright so popular twitch streamer
destiny recently launched a nuclear
missile filled with drama
live on stream he accused another
streamer of manipulation
of pressuring women into sending nude
photos and of sexual harassment
now we know all about these allegations
because there's
65 pages of testimony and over a
dozen hours of people yelling about them
yeah this story is a mess
all right guys the score esports is on
the road to two million subs but we need
your help to get there
so grab your mom grab your friend grab
your dog and get them all to scroll down
and hit that little red subscribe button
for me
now i'm not kidding when i say this
story is unwieldy there are so many
side stories and ancillary people
involved that we would be here for three
hours if i went through every single
detail
at its core this story involves four
people all of them are streamers
just chatting personality political
commentator and [ __ ] disturber destiny
his fiancee molina big boss bose or just
bose and bob seven it's worth noting two
things before we jump in
first bob seven used to be a producer on
the austin show one of the most popular
talk shows on twitch
this will come up later second destiny
and molina have an open relationship
which means they're free to see other
people while also being engaged to one
another
now i know that fact might seem
inconsequential
but it's literally one of the reasons
why we're talking about this drama in
the first place so
here we are all right all of the destiny
drama started on january 4th
when destiny posted a youtube video
talking pretty vaguely
about a ton of allegations of harassment
involving bob seven
molina and bose he specifically mentions
bob7 allegedly leaking women's nude
photos
of sharing deeply personal information
about destiny to other people
and just generally talking a [ __ ] ton of
trash about him
to those same people so when i have this
feeling that there exists somebody like
in my personal life that is like
connecting to every single person i talk
to it's also like [ __ ] talking me behind
the scenes
um it's starting to like this is like
severely impacting my
like judge like makes me feel very bad
okay this is [ __ ]
hard and when this video dropped the
live stream fails subreddit and whoever
else cares about this [ __ ]
were one giant question mark seriously
people were either confused as had
already found bob7 guilty
or were shaking their heads at the
absurdity of what we all
knew we were about to get the response
and on january 14th we got bob's 39
page response to destiny's video
allegations
since then we've gotten another 17 page
response
and a three hour stream on the subject
from destiny
plus statements from at least two other
people
and of course when people realize that
they had to read at least
39 pages in order to understand this
story
they didn't they didn't read the pages
but i did
now in order to tell a short but still
comprehensive version of this story
we actually have to go back all the way
to april april is when molina and bob
seven started talking over dms and
pretty quickly they grew really close
destiny said he didn't care
remember they had an open relationship
now there is a ton
of he said he said she said she said she
said in this story
but on this fact everyone can agree
at some point molina started venting to
bob7 about her relationship with destiny
speaking of open relationships while
melina grew close with bob7 from
april onwards destiny started chatting
with another streamer named bose
and by september they had also grown
quite close
now the timeline of events isn't really
what's being disputed here
it's the interpretation of those events
and the opinions of those involved
that varies wildly here's a good example
let's jump ahead to november 6th the
inciting incident as it's referred to
in all of these responses that night
bose and bob seven streamed together
once the stream wrapped they spent the
next five hours chatting
and bob allegedly shared a ton of
personal [ __ ] he knew about destiny with
bows and that's when everything started
to go wrong now this situation
hell this entire video boils down to
this
point destiny accused bob 7 of
manipulation
and of trying to turn all of destiny's
friends against him
it's where the story starts and honestly
it's where the story ends
now on the other hand bob7 accuses
destiny of trying to destroy him for
months and at this point bose accuses
destiny of not being honest with her
molina thinks bose hates her bose thinks
the opposite
and destiny is just trying to figure out
what the [ __ ] is going on now
all of what i've just told you and a lot
of what we're going to talk about
happened behind the scenes and we're
just now finding out about it due to
destiny's video
and the subsequent documents and streams
sure you always hear
bits and pieces of things on stream and
the live stream fails subreddit is
always
speculating but in this case the drama
already happened
and now that it's out the truth is being
litigated online
side note i think it's hilarious how
twitch drama is slowly being codified
40 page documents inciting incidences
16 000 messages six stone sold all being
normalized
broken down and made official that
is truly wild now in his response bob7
says that he was just trying to give
genuine advice to molina and that he
would often consult
bows on what was going on he says he
wasn't trying to get them to hate
destiny he goes on to address all of the
allegations
and issues that destiny brought up in
his january 4th
video he provides an extensive timeline
and talks about how destiny allegedly
manipulated
other people into hating bob seven and
here's bob7 on why he felt the need to
be so
thorough about his conversations with
molina and bose
and his response hey why is this being
brought out okay i will tell you why
this is being brought out
the reason that this is being brought
out because the reason that destiny
hates me is because i was giving
molina genuine advice because i was
giving bose genuine advice
and i was a direct threat to him
manipulating these girls
okay that is why this happens that is
why he hates me that is why i have to
show
that he painted me as this manipulative
person now bob7 says that he reached out
to destiny on november 25th
to try to smooth things over but
apparently destiny
wasn't having and a common theme
throughout bob seven's response
is the idea that destiny is a master
manipulator hell-bent on destroying him
now you have to remember with
all of this destiny is much bigger than
bob7 so obviously there's going to be
more people on his side alright
once again everyone agrees that what
happened next
did happen it's more about who you want
to believe
in this situation in both his january
4th video and the 17 page response he
published
destiny talks about a series of events
that happened when he molina and bose
went to georgia to help canvas for
senate elections apparently molina and
bose hashed things out and allegedly
realized that bob seven was manipulating
them both
this then turned into a 10 person
discord call involving women
bob 7 had allegedly manipulated all
figuring out they had been sold the same
pack of lies
at some point like i go upstairs into
the hotel room
and there's like [ __ ] like 10 girls
on a
group call and they're all talking it
felt like a
movie isn't there some movie where like
four girls all find out they're dating
the same guy or some [ __ ]
like these ten girls you know these ten
girls in this
group calling they're all talking about
like holy [ __ ] like bob seven has like
said all the same [ __ ] to me
like he's throwing you under the bus
like oh my god like you talk [ __ ] about
you'll tell me oh my god like there's
this girl he says you're
ugly and like oh my god like i'm pretty
sure like he sent me like you screen
share like your
nudes and [ __ ] on this and it was like
all this crazy [ __ ]
now at this point you might be thinking
holy [ __ ] this is
actually a minefield and while you might
be right
none of it is really surprising now for
most of the people involved
especially destiny this is kind of what
they
do whether it's political personal or
hell even philosophical
streamers like destiny get involved now
something else that came from the
discord call is the allegation that bob7
got drunk called another streamer by the
name of ophelia bear
and sexually harassed her it's also
alleged that bob7 pressured an
unknown woman into sending nude photos
she didn't want to send
and then immediately sharing them with
molina after the fact now eventually
molina bose and a few other people got
on a call with austin who if you somehow
don't know
hosts the austin show which is one of
the most popular talk shows on twitch
and remember at this point bob7 was
still a producer
for the austin show they told austin
about what bob7 had allegedly said to
ophelia bear
which led to austin firing bob because
of it now bob7 obviously denies
all of this the pressuring women into
sending nude photos the manipulation and
sexual harassment
all of it he says that beau specifically
was going to other women
and lying about him and he says that
bose forced ophelia bear to come forward
with her sexual harassment story
when allegedly she didn't want to and
because her name was now involved
ophelia bear then released a statement
saying she felt manipulated by
both sides she was upset that bose
dragged her into this situation
and honestly she wanted nothing to do
with it and really that's just about
it now obviously nobody came out of this
looking good
and i don't have to tell you that this
should have been kept private because
that was the biggest response from the
internet
everybody is still streaming we still
don't know who manipulated who
bob7 has still lost his job and before
you know it
twitch is gonna move on to the next
batch of drama and when that inevitably
happens
i'll be right back here probably reading
another 40-page document
12 hours hours dust
how do nest destiny how destiny and
destiny
destiny who the [ __ ] is destiny destiny
is much
bigger and bob's for the viewers out
there
this is a lot of work all right like
so if you enjoy this [ __ ] i mean i'm
glad and like hopefully we'll give you
more of it
but god damn dude
[Music]